[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantly kissing
and this is the show for you
if you're bored of people arguing on the
internet over subjects they know nothing
about
at trigonometry we don't pretend to be
the experts we
ask the experts our fantastic expert
guest
this week is the associate director of
the institute of economic affairs
kay andrews welcome to trigonometry
thanks for having me
[Music]
oh it's so great to have you we've been
trying to get you on the show for a long
time now i'm very happy to be here oh
we're
really excited to have you um uh before
we get into the interview just tell our
viewers who you are
how are you where you are a little bit
about kind of your political evolution
as well perhaps
sure um my name's kate uh i'm the
associate director as you said of the
institute of economic affairs
i'm american i came to scotland in 2008
to study
um spent four years there uh went back
to the states for a little bit and ended
up coming back to work at the adam smith
institute i know you guys interviewed
sam bowman he used to be their executive
director
i was there for two years moved over to
the ia um
i guess as a kid i was always very
interested in what what was happening in
politics and
particularly policy actually i i liked
sort of the nitty gritty details from a
strangely young age but i think that my
my philosophy definitely developed over
the course of university
i actually did an internship at the iaea
and that's when i realized oh my gosh
libertarianism classical liberalism
individualism uh it brought together
things that i
firmly believed and was always trying to
put into a political slant
but realized that there was a philosophy
behind it too uh and then i decided
why not do it for a job and although it
wasn't that easy like my visa is the
bane of my existence
but uh you know i took some effort but
uh here i am
brilliant we're very glad you're here uh
let's get straight into it
one of the things that you are known i
think for talking about i see you on tv
quite regularly talking about the gender
pay gap
uh in doing the research for this i was
looking on youtube and pretty much
every video that is entitled anything
like smart woman destroys
radical feminist with facts has you as
the smart woman customer
i did not upload those videos and i i
hate those headlines
i think they're so i i hate the age of
click bait but i
yes i have seen some of them so you've
never destroyed a snowflake
i wouldn't word it like that i wouldn't
hurt it like that i'm sure i've been
destroyed too
you know you you you win and you lose
something oh i get destroyed every
episode
i look forward to that part of this one
yeah um but yeah so i
that's actually you know we don't do
that either like with this show we don't
put
stuff out like yeah no i know it's it's
much more thoughtful which i find more
interesting
so do we and i think that you're gonna
grow slower
uh doing that it's much faster to just
go destroys this destroys that but i
think
the benefit of kind of cultivating an
audience that's interested in nuance and
a genuine conversation
that's much better so anyway you're
destroying people online is what we
started with uh on the gender pay gap so
why don't you destroy us about the
gender pay gap or tell us rather what it
is
what are your thoughts on it why are you
critical of this so the gender pay gap
is the average difference in the pay of
men and women who are working
this is different from equal pay equal
pay is is asking the question
uh are men and women who are doing the
same job
under the same circumstances with the
same background is one getting paid more
because their man is one getting paid
less because they're a woman
whereas with the gender pay gap you're
looking at averages so people often say
so are you saying that there's no gender
pay gap no i'm saying that there are
an infinite number of gender pay gaps
because you can calculate that average
amongst anyone you want we could do a
gender pay gap right now between us
or charities so you might turn out well
uh you know we could calculate gender
pay gap between
the boss and the junior researcher who's
22 years old who just started
we could calculate a gender pay gap
between people who work at goldman sachs
versus people who work at the ia
or oxfam or any other charity uh so for
me the question on the gender pay gap is
what are you actually measuring
obviously some of those calculations are
going to be a lot more meaningful than
others
and often you find with a lot of these
gimmicky campaigns and efforts
they're going to great lengths to make
the worst calculation possible
to come up with the biggest statistic
that they can
and that's where myself and i think a
lot of other young women now are trying
to step in and saying wait a second
this isn't true you know statistics can
tell you anything they want but what's
the most
factual analysis we can get on this and
uh that's where where we step in and we
try to come up with some more legitimate
figures
well the media concept of the gender
cape the way they present it i don't
think they would ever elaborate on it
that way but the way they present is
essentially
for every pound that a a man earns a
woman earns
whatever 77 83 in the states yeah
that's the idea and what you're saying
is
what what they're doing is essentially
they're adding up the all the earnings
of men
on average the adding of donors and
women averaging that and comparing the
two
and that doesn't reflect things like
choices uh
take time off work career choices you
know things like that right that's
definitely true
but even those statements women are
earning you know x amount of pence
to the pound or the dollar those are
just false you know that is that
well that's essentially implying a
question of equal pay right
you know for every pound a man earns a
woman will earn x that's
no that's not true you then have to ask
yourself
what is the circumstance because it
could be that for every pound a woman
earns
who is a ceo at a bank a man earns
x percentage less right so you know i
think that
statement in and of itself is extremely
misleading if not
downright wrong so let's look at the
figures in the uk
uh the most popular statistic used well
not necessarily most popular but uh the
one you'll see perhaps in you know on
the big
on the big media screens is 18.4
that is the gender pay gap in the uk
that statistics calculated by the office
for national statistics which does a
really good job of calculating the pay
gap
but that combines full-time workers and
part-time workers
we know that women are significantly
more likely to work part-time and that
those jobs tend to pay less
so i think in and of itself that is a
really unfair calculation you're not
comparing like for like
if you just separate part-time workers
from full-time workers that's all you've
done you still have not taken into
account age
job background children anything you get
9.1 pay gap for full-time workers
negative 5.1 pay gap for part-time
workers
so that's a pay gap in favor of women so
part-time workers who are female
actually out earn their male
counterparts
yes exactly so just by doing that one
thing
you've cut the pay gap in half for
full-time and you've actually shown that
women are doing better on average and
part-time
work so that just goes to show how how
manipulated these statistics statistics
can be when you just are taking one
thing
into account then when you start to go
into age start to go into background
you know the pay gap gets smaller and
smaller and smaller
so in the uk women between the ages of
22 to 39
are basically earning the same as men
the pay gap is negligible
in 2015 women age 22 to 29 were earning
slightly more
tiny percentage right now men are
earning 2
2.5 percent more and that's a negligible
statistic so you know we can actually
say that the gender pay gap has been
eradicated
for men and women between the ages of 20
and 40. that's a huge part of your
working life you know that's
absolutely fantastic i think the pay gap
that still exists after that age has a
lot to do
with maternity leave and the fact that
women take years off work on average
compared to men
it has to do with a lot of choices that
women are making in terms of jobs and
work culture and what they value
it has a lot to do with whether or not
you're willing to work overtime willing
to work weekends that feeds into job
culture and all that
and none of those things and job the
actual job that you choose to do
none of those things are calculated in
the pay gap so even the
very basic statistics we have are
showing a pretty good picture for women
the pay gap's the lowest it's ever been
on record since i started calculating it
in the uk
um and you know that hasn't taken into
account very important things
so if that's the case and you're saying
that it's negligible then
why are we constantly getting bombarded
with these facts and statistics about
how women
are being out earned by men we live in
an unfair society we live in a sexist
society
why why are we getting that story
well i have two theories one's generous
and one isn't
which which one do you want first let's
go both as well okay i'll start
i think the generous one is that it's
2018
it's it's an important year it's a
hundred women a hundred women it's a
hundred years
hundred years since women got the vote
in the uk uh
and something still doesn't feel quite
right you know
as a woman in 2018 you still recognize
that a lot of the cards are stacked
against you you know look at divi
uh look at domestic violence stats look
at rape statistics
compare men and women walking home alone
on any given evening
you know women have their car keys in
their in their fingers and men
don't something still doesn't feel right
it doesn't seem fair
and i think that that very legitimate
feeling that we can all pretty much
agree on
uh then people want to to harness that
and say well what are we going to do
about it
and unfortunately people
go to the gender pay gap because they
think it's something that they can
really easily solve through legislation
they think well i want to see results i
want to get a law passed i want to get
something done
let's focus on the gender pay gap
because we can make the state
make big business publish their pay gap
figures you know we can do something and
say we got a win we got a policy win
um but of course that that has no
meaningful impact on the things that i
think women are still actually facing
and the disadvantages that we have in
society
so i mean that would be my generous
reading of it that people just want to
do something about the unfairness that
they still see in the world
so they latch onto the pay gap even
though that's not where we need to be
latching on to if anything
we can say this seems to be going
extremely well there's still some things
we could do to help women in work for
sure
but this is not the major area we need
to look at violence we need to look at
yarlswood detention center where
immigrant women are kept and detained
and treated horribly you know that's
what we need to look at
my last generous reading
is that you know it's a lucrative and
popular business to be
promoting victimhood culture and
the larger the statistic the more media
attention you'll get
um you know if you look at a lot of
these articles across the spectrum it's
no particular publication
you know if easyjet was a really good
example when businesses had to publish
their pay gap figures for the first time
back in april
um you know every headline was easyjet
has 52
gender pay gap massive um you had to get
to article six oh sorry paragraph six or
seven
um if it was in the article at all uh
where it said
actually the reason that they have this
pay gap is that they pay their pilots a
hundred grand a year
they pay the stewards 25 grand a year
they six percent of their pilots are
women 94
are men this is double the worldwide
average of female pilots
they're actually doing really well they
can't hire more female pilots because
they don't exist
they implemented a program years back
with their own profits off their own
back to bring in more women by 2020
this is a company that is doing
everything it can to encourage women
support women and to pay them fairly and
equally
and this is the reason for their pay gap
but that was not at the top of the
article
that was if you're lucky at the bottom
so those big statistics sell
i think there's a real effort right now
to press the reset button on the gender
pay gap
it really wasn't that long ago you know
40 years ago where you could see
a genuine pay gap that was based on
discrimination that women got paid less
than men
and that has closed so dramatically for
a lot of reasons including the fact that
women are getting better educated
they're more educated than men on
average and they're going on to do those
top jobs
uh you know they're extremely motivated
there isn't that glass ceiling anymore
and uh you know that pay gap has been
shrinking and shrinking and shrinking
which is great news it's a wonderful
story to tell especially young women
and a lot of these groups that do very
well perpetuating that victimhood
mentality
need to press a reset button they need
to be able to say that something's still
wrong here in order to have relevance
and they've been really successful i
mean up until april
the pay gap the biggest one you could
come up with was 18.4
but that's quite misleading you know
we've got this great story about 9.1
percent
negative 5.1 percent and then they get
these big businesses without
much context at all to publish their pay
gap statistics
and now they can say 52 gender pay gap
70 gender pay gap it's as if you know
the past 50 years didn't exist
and that's great for them it's a really
bad message for normal women who are
just going to work in the morning
pouring a cup of coffee
now thinking to themselves oh i work for
easy chat are they discriminating
against me
no they want to perpetuate you they want
to bring you up they want to
propel you to top spots actually but
if you just read the headline a lot of
people do you're going to have a pretty
negative attitude
so that's my slightly more skeptical
perspective i think they're trying to
push the reset button
to make this issue still relevant i
think it's really terrible for young
women
especially to see this because that's
not what's really happening
for them when they get out of university
when they're going into the workforce
they're in a great position do you
believe in the glass ceiling for women
or do you think that
i mean because that's been talked about
a lot the fact that there's not that
many female ceos
it's predominantly male dominated do you
see that as being a real problem
industry in industry at the moment or do
you think we've
sort of evolved past that i don't see it
as being a problem in industry
i think there's an issue culturally so
businesses know
that diversity will make them profitable
they know that diversity
helps them it brings them profits it
helps them to succeed so can you find
out how how do they know that what is
there some kind of study that shows
yeah i mean there's a whole array of
evidence that the more diverse your
boards are your staff is the more likely
you are
to see that translate into profits yeah
diversity equals profits
and businesses know this and a lot of
them are desperate
to bring up women uh and i don't think
that glass ceiling exists
inside business now don't get me wrong
there's always going to be
that jerk you know usually a man
some jerk who doesn't think that women
are as good as men that happens that's
why
he got in there which one he got in
there first
i was just about to do that same joke
all right
uh well there's always going to be one
or two in the room
who don't think that women can cut it
and
they're always going to be jerks and
that's why we have equal pay legislation
because if that happens to you that's
illegal and you can go to court and you
can
sue them which is exactly what you
should do but generally speaking this is
not the attitude in workplaces work
places want to elevate and lift women up
i think if we do have a problem and i
i think we probably do to some extent
it's much more cultural
uh it's the fact that uh there are
studies that show that
um you know if if a man and a woman are
doing a very similar job getting paid
similarly working similar
hours women are still likely to do
significantly more housework
and home chores than a man uh it would
be ridiculous to pretend
that we don't not we're not sitting here
thinking it right but subconsciously
most of us still think that women are
going to be the primary caretakers it's
just the downright assumption
if if a couple has children the woman's
going to stay home to some extent and
look after the kid
you know it's mom who gets called by the
school nurse it's not dad
and i think culturally we have not
evolved
as much as we'd like to pretend and it
means that women are taking
years off of work it means they're not
going to be promoted in the same way
their lifelong earnings are not going to
be as high
they're not going to become the ceo
because they've taken all this time out
of the company
and i think businesses are a lot if they
have the money and not every business
does but if they have the money you see
great examples of businesses bending
over backwards
to have daycare on site very generous
paternity as well as maternity pay
but not every business can do that and
you know culturally we just haven't
advanced enough
uh to be able to say well you know what
the man's earning a bit less maybe he
should be the one to stay home
and when sure parental leave was brought
in in 2015
you know this was a great step right you
can genuinely divide up
who's going to take leave now and i
think it was reported early this year or
maybe late last year that
two percent of men who are eligible have
taken it up
not that's a choice and that's a choice
that we are making as individuals no
employer
is enforcing that um but you know these
are really hard conversations
well do you think that's just culture
though because you know we've had
evolutionary psychologists on the show
and
you know other people who would say you
had diana she's fabulous
now i'm not sure that she necessarily
said this but
my sense of what she was saying was she
was talking about the fact that some of
these things
are evolutionary biological and some of
them are evolutionary psychological so
essentially i think a lot of people
would say
well women are better adapted at looking
after kids they're more likely to want
to do it than men
and this is not just down to culture
it's down to thousands and thousands of
evolution do you think that's an element
or do you think it's just cultural it
would be really silly
to ignore the choices that people are
obviously
choosing to make so sweden provides the
perfect example of this in sweden
they brought in shared parental leave
really early on very progressive back in
the 70s
and they reassessed it in the 90s and
they realized that an overwhelming
majority of women were still taking the
bulk of the time off
and so they brought in what i like to
call forced dad leave
they basically said if the dad doesn't
take a certain percentage of this time
off you're going to lose some of your
benefits you're not going to get the
same number of days off you're not going
to get the same subsidies
and still in sweden you have the
majority of women
taking the time majority of time taken
up by women
and some people are foregoing their
benefits because the women want as much
time with their newborn as possible
we'd be silly to ignore that and i think
we're going to come to this a bit later
on but
that's a really hard one because on the
one hand
it's really stupid to ignore what
majorities are telling you
on the other hand i believe very
strongly in
rejecting stereotypes whenever possible
and treating people's individuals
so it's a really hard one to to balance
especially in terms of public policy
but i think you create an atmosphere you
create public policy
based on giving everyone the opportunity
to do what they want to do
which is why i think shared parental
leave in the uk is so fantastic
um and there's some issues there
paternity leave is not as well paid as
maternity leave i would like to see it
be better paid
we need to address that but you create
the opportunities and then you let
individuals do what they want to do
and we shouldn't be surprised when more
women take that time off
than men i think where i don't
think it's just biological but it's
cultural pressures as well
is when you see how women's behavior
changes based on what
she thinks society wants her to do
so i don't i don't remember the name of
the study but the new york times had a
fantastic piece not too long ago
where they flagged up a study where
young women
fairly young women were asked about
their career ambitions what they wanted
to be paid and what they wanted to
achieve professionally
write it down and then when they were
told
that a prospective life partner might
see the answers
they downgraded their expectations for
both their job
and their salary oh wow with the
assumption
that they with that a man would be
intimidated by
her ambitions the same piece flagged up
a different study where they showed
that successful men were very happy
for their female partner to make money
very happy for her to be successful
just as long as she earned slightly less
than he did
and you know this this is this is
something to tackle
and uh you know i i think that is that
is cultural and it is something that we
need to be extremely aware of
i'm 28 and the expectation
on women in their 20s is absolutely
hilarious so when you're 22 and you've
graduated from university everyone's
like
be single have a great time don't get
you know don't get bogged down just go
out and be single
and then at 25 it's like have you met
someone and then
you know at 28 29 30 it's like so
where's where's the ring where are the
kids
apparently you're supposed to be all
three of those things in like an
eight-year time period
it's a joke it's an absolute joke but
let's not pretend that that expectation
isn't being put on women in particular
um is there a men to some extent there
are other pressures on men
but again their biological differences
there like a woman has a certain time
whether a man doesn't and that's always
going to be the pressure isn't it
although quality of sperm does degrade
so there you go
you learn something that's what women
are thinking about when they meet with
the bar
absolutely but yeah they're you're right
there is uh there is a biological clock
that's ticking
um but also you know what if she's not
so bothered about having kids what if
that's not the priority and yet
everyone's putting that upon her so you
know i think all of these things factor
into the gender pay gap
and they're really interesting to
discuss and we need to tackle a lot of
them
public policy wise culturally i just
think that
always the blame is put on employers and
they're probably the least to blame
you know i think they're the ones who
are actually creating the opportunities
for women
and in terms of public policy and
culture that's where we need to make the
adjustments to help them
and so that really frustrates me and
it's not i mean yeah demonizing business
is
is not ideal if the business hasn't done
anything wrong but it's about
the women really it's about the women
going to work in these places
and how they're going to feel day in day
out if they're just having
really large misleading statistics in
their head because somebody put them
there and they're unfair
so i can guess what your answer is going
to be but i feel necessary to ask it
anyway
do you believe in quotas as in you're so
you know hard no
quotas are the worst um no i don't
believe in quotas
uh quotas are essentially by
by definition suggesting that women
can't achieve as much as men without
help
this is deeply insulting and as
a woman how could she ever feel
confident that you had earned your
position within a company
as an elected representative on a board
wherever it is how could you feel
confident that you earned it
if you had a quota system in place am i
there
because i'm great because i crushed it
because i'm the best
or am i there because i was a box
ticking exercise
and i do not want to sit down at the
table with my male colleagues looking at
me wondering if she was a box ticking
exercise
i want them to know i'm there because
i'm good
oh i would feel horrific being promoted
under a quota system i feel absolutely
horrible
it's interesting how this cultural meme
of the gender pay gap
has become so powerful though because
i'm just thinking in my head
if i go on stage tonight in a comedy
club and i go hey i just spoke to
kate andrews and she says there's no
gender pay gap
i would be booed off stage probably you
right i'd love to be at that yeah i know
you would
i'd start the boeing yeah you would well
i thought a lot of that comes down to
all these misleading statistics right
and people think you're just crazy to
deny a 70
gender pay gap because if there is a 70
gender pay gap
and it's based on actually equal pay
issues and discrimination that's
horrific
and so you know a lot of people just
won't know the details of it which is
why it's important to
to share this um but i also think again
if we're being generous it goes back to
that
to that issue of people feeling like
well you know
let's not beat up on women they don't
have a uzi all the time
um but when to be so much more
productive to talk about areas where
we could really use better public policy
where we could use better support of the
law
to help us you know when it comes to
really serious issues like crime
[Music]
so what is the role for feminism is
there a role for feminism in your
opinion uh
in in kind of in the west now today do
you think we need something else
there is a role for feminism if used
correctly but
has not been used correctly for a very
very long time
and i get very frustrated when people
say well
feminism is just believing that men and
women are equal so if you're not a
feminist
you don't believe that that has not been
the definition of feminism
for a long time and you cannot have the
opinions that i have
which are about statistics and
calculations and economics about the
gender pay gap
and be accepted in feminist circles you
just can't
um you're not allowed you're not you
know you have internalized
uh which is something people say to you
yeah
honestly it's baffling but people really
do say that um
if you don't if you don't fit they're
very limited criteria of what it means
to be a feminist
then you don't get to be part of the
club and that you know
most women don't identify as feminists
in the uk the majority don't anyway
and there's a reason for that and it's
because of course women don't fit into
these little boxes you want to fit them
into we're people
we're human um you know i thought we
were trying to show the world
that women are breaking out of that
stereotype of being barbies that were
real treat us
treat us as real people and uh you know
i feel like the feminism ideology in the
uk and the us very much in the western
world
is actually really about being something
very specific
and i just i can't sign up to it i i did
not applaud david schwimmer
when he invited a chaperone to his
meeting with a woman
at his hotel and because she might feel
uncomfortable
you know i do i do not applaud men going
back to the victorian era
i i i do i i can't get on board with you
know the major spokespeople of feminism
like lena dunham who think that
having sushi on college campus
cafeterias is cultural appropriation
these are not the issues that i want to
be discussing when it comes to women
and our advancements so you know
feminism has really let me down in that
way and i've been thinking recently this
year actually
about trying to reclaim it and what that
might mean
because when the pay gap reporting
measures came out and when they were
trying to press that reset button
i got really emotional about it i was
like no you can't do this
we're doing too well you can't take that
away from us we need to share those
stories
and so there would be real merit in
trying to reclaim it but it's an uphill
battle and i don't really know where to
begin
so you're saying that you know feminism
in a sense focuses on the wrong issues
what should it be focusing on
i think it should be focusing on the
very serious issues related to our
safety
and our health that we still face in the
states and in the uk and in the west
it should be significantly more focused
on what's happening
around the rest of the world where women
don't have the right to health care
don't have the right to drive don't have
the right to wear the outfits they want
don't have the right to a fair trial
don't have the right to vote
you know these are the stories that we
should be flagging up well exactly like
in iran right now women are risking
their lives not to wear a head scarf
and then you see feminists talking here
about you know
what cultural appropriation because of
sushi or whatever and you just kind of
you go
how do these things coexist priorities
exactly yeah it's it's really depressing
um
you know the metoo movement started out
very organic
i liked it when it first began because
it was women
sharing their stories in a very open
very honest way about sexual assault
um you know i'm not gonna keep this to
myself anymore i'm not embarrassed i'm
not
i refuse to hold on to that shame i'm
putting out into the world so people can
hear my voice
what a wonderful thing to do and then
how quickly did that get hijacked
by people who wanted to talk about the
gender pay gap by
you know actresses who think that
wearing a couture dress which
essentially costs what most people
average salary is
you know to talk about issues of the pay
gap and to wear all black and whatnot
you know why don't you just bring some
of those women from iran why don't you
bring detainees who got out of yarrow's
wood
onto the red carpet with you that would
be much more meaningful
um than than these silly campaigns and
you know i i find the state of it really
depressing
which is why i think you know some of
the best work being done
is the work that's highlighting to young
women how well they're actually doing
is the genuine charity work reaching out
to developing countries and countries
that are suffering under oppression
and doing what they can to help women
there it's not coming from the feminist
movement
so how do you identify yourself if
you're not a feminist if you had to
put an easy label on yourself she told
you she's got it
internalized exactly
i'll just have to go outside and ask the
men out there who pay me to say what i
say
what my ideology is give me a second um
yeah uh how do i describe myself to be
honest
um i i'll give credit to somebody else
um and i don't think she knows this
uh but i spoke on a panel about feminism
years back and i was there with uh
professor emily skarbeck
who she used to teach at um king's
college london
and she's now i believe at brown and i
was on the panel with her and i mean
she's a real economist she she knows
herself she knows her numbers and she
was talking about the pay gap from that
perspective
and she was asked how she described
herself and and she said
uh you know i call myself an
individualist because i think it
encompasses everything that is good
about feminism
but also allows me to recognize that
stereotyping is wrong
that everyone has their own point of
view and that every circumstance is
unique
and that really stuck with me and that
is
what i would call myself now when it
comes to cultural issues i'm an
individualist
because to go back before about biology
and you know what do women really want
what do men want
you know i'm i'm classically liberal i
believe in free people
uh people you know having every
opportunity given to them and then
making their own choices as long as it
doesn't harm anybody else
and i think individualism encompasses
that
i don't want a stereotype i think it's i
think it'd be very dangerous if we
assume that because she's a woman
she'll want to have lots of babies and
she won't you know she'll want a nice
work-life balance
i think it's dangerous to assume that a
man you know is going to be really
competitive and wants to work evenings
we have to try to treat people
individually so that allows me
to to believe in equality of the sexes
it allows me to think that men and women
are capable of doing the same things
but to speak to you and speak to you and
speak to you behind the camera and speak
to everybody out there
you don't have to speak to them as a
producer it doesn't matter
where the stars no he's an individual no
no no to me anyway carry on
i feel bad every time you do that
because he doesn't get a chance to reply
yeah you can insult me because i'll make
fun of you the next that's why i insult
you because he can't in his eyes yeah
um yeah i it allows it allows me to
treat everybody
and look at specifically and differently
and it
allows me to acknowledge their
circumstances and
interact with them in that way which is
so much nicer than putting people into
boxes
what one of the things that i really
abhor i think is probably the right word
about the the feminist movement
is like you said it's just if you
challenge them in whatever way
or you disagree with them like my
girlfriend is currently in the last year
of her doctor incredibly intelligent
doing a
psychological psychology degree and she
says that she disagrees with abc dna of
the modern feminist movement
but she would never ever voice those
opinions because she would fear being
slandered
having labels attached to her do you
think that's part of the problem with
the movement
is the moment you say well look i
disagree with this immediately you get
six people jumping down your throats
putting labels on you and
it's not a real discussion anymore oh
yeah there's a lot of name calling but
we're just living in a world where
everyone wants to label each other
it is a consequence of identity politics
that
you know there is a real desire to
understand you
based on very very superficial things um
like like you know she's a feminist i
understand what that ideology means and
so i i can put her here and i get that
and um you know i i don't think it
allows you to get to know the individual
and there's definitely that threat i
mean
if she did come out and start talking
about that she probably would get called
names
uh and you know have a tougher time with
it than if she just put her head down
and believed it but didn't want to weigh
in on the discussion
um we have more young women talking
about it though and not just young women
we have women across the spectrum
talking about this and how they don't
like being stereotyped
and that's great you know i do think it
is becoming
slowly but surely an atmosphere where
women can voice their dissent a little
bit more
against you know what you're supposed to
say what you're supposed to do
and supposed to be as a woman i mean
this is crazy i thought we fought
against this
uh but yeah you know it would be rough
that's not gonna lie it is fascinating
how that works isn't it because for
decades i think the feminist movement
the radical feminist
elements of the movement have been
shutting people down based on identity
politics if a white man like francis was
to say something
and challenge them right that's what the
response would be you're a white man you
shouldn't be allowed to say this
and now what you're seeing is radical
feminists who are trans-exclusionary or
whatever they don't believe certain
things that they're supposed to believe
according to the modern
diversity agenda they are the ones that
are being shut down because
they're uh a straight white middle-class
woman
and that's now become a label that can
be used as a pejorative
it's amazing yeah and where does this
end who's going to be allowed to speak
at the end of all of this well that's
the thing about identity politics is
that the more you can break it down
and the you know the more boxes you can
tick and the fewer boxes you fit into
will define your privilege
uh but you know this is this is a crazy
way to look at the world
what is somebody's background you know
regardless of their skin color or their
gender
and things that we can see on the
outside what have they been through what
has their experience been like
um and and this frustrates me because as
somebody who believes in including trans
women
um very much so in in in the
conversations about women
i would much prefer to speak to radical
feminists
about their opinions rather than to
judge them
on who they physically are yeah you know
i want to debate i want to have those
conversations they're interesting
they're important we need to have that
publicly we need to get that out there
um so let's debate it but i just can't
imagine ever looking at you or you or
sitting across from someone
and assuming that i can shut them down
because of what is being presented to me
um it's it's horrible it's it's very bad
for public discussion
and you've said in the past i think i
saw one of the interviews that this is
part of a leftist
kind of movement ideology how what's the
link there between feminism and this
kind of
left-wing ideology well i think no not
at all i think
um you know i think over the past few
decades it's essentially become
an arm of a left-wing movement
because if you look at what they're
calling for they're calling for
much more intervention they want
government to step in
frequently to solve the problems and
they've gone far past the law which i
mean i completely agree with we need to
protect people under the law from
harm but you know they want the
government to legislate around business
they want it to legislate around all
kinds of things
and uh you know that's that's very
traditionally very
left-wing and
especially the way that politics pans
out in the states as well
to say that you are say a feminist
republican
people would look at you and think that
that couldn't go together
and that shouldn't be the case you
should be able to be a feminist anything
if we're going back to the original
definition but that's
i think that proves that we're not at
that original definition anymore
because people would just think you had
contradicted yourself
[Music]
and i know that you're a fan of
socialist paradises
yeah well i mean i love them in theory
because real socialism hasn't been tried
i love them in theory yeah definitely um
my uh for the regular viewers will know
my mother is uh from a socialist
paradise
venezuela we're doing really well at the
moment guys
a million percent inflation how many
people got that in their math test
right so uh would you like to give a
little bit background to our
to our viewers i mean because what's
happening in venezuela starting to
become more and more
white well worldwide and and that people
can see
for themselves yes thank goodness that
it's becoming
more covered by the media and i mean it
wasn't that long ago
five six years ago where you had very
prominent uk politicians
very prominent philosophers like noam
chomsky talking about how venezuela
showed us that another way was possible
and they meant that in a good way not
that not that another way is possible
you know here's utter travesty um it's
really horrific what's happened under
the socialist policies
chavez is definitely responsible but
it's become much worse as well under
the current president nicholas maduro
over the course of a decade they
they seized over a thousand companies
in the private sector and you know just
a huge array of nationalization
and since oil prices have tanked the way
that they were able to sustain their
economy a bit has completely crashed
and now you have over two million people
fleeing
venezuela and an estimated 2.5 million
more by 2020
so to put it in perspective this kind of
mass emigration from venezuela is on the
same scale as the syrian crisis
and we need to treat it as such it is a
human rights disaster what's happened
there
and it is socialism in
in every way um there's nothing about it
that wasn't real
there's nothing about it that you know
you can blame on the capitalists
this is what happens when you believe
that through force
the state can control our lives and it's
really sad
um and you know i i actually think
most people know this deep down you know
i don't i don't think most people really
do think
that venezuela shows us that another way
is possible
um and it's not to say
that we can't have a debate about more
intervention versus left intervention
higher taxes versus lower taxes it's not
about that
this is about the way that you control
the means of production
um you know it they always jump around
about what the new socialism is and i've
heard a lot recently that scandinavia
is actually what we should aspire to
because that's socialist i mean the
scandinavian countries are
fundamentally capitalist they understand
that the best
the most the very best way to create
wealth
is through a capitalist system then we
can talk about redistributing it
you might think taxes should be a bit
higher i might think they should be a
bit lower
you might think the safety net should be
bigger i might think it should be
smaller
but we can have that debate once that
wealth has been created through
capitalism
and you know in the scandinavian
countries norway sweden denmark
you know they're fundamentally
capitalist uh if you look at sweden in
particular
um their education system is based on
that very famous socialist thinker
milton friedman
uh you know they have significantly more
private provisions in their health care
system than we do in the uk
uh you know these are these a few of
them don't even have a minimum wage
you know these are not countries that
are socialist um
so i'm not trying to shut down the
debate between the left and the right
that's a necessary one it's a valuable
one to have
um you said earlier in the discussion
that you know
these actually when we first started we
were talking about these videos that
talk about
destroying yeah feminism whatever it is
and um one of the reasons i don't like
clickbait is because
none of these ideas ever get destroyed
and you know i think
people who believe in individualism
and liberty and free markets and free
people
thought that they had won that argument
they thought they had destroyed
socialism but it always rears its ugly
head
and uh we're fighting the battle once
more so you've never destroyed
the other idea the other ideas the other
side you're always having to make the
arguments
which is why free speech is so important
it's why you know
not telling people that they can't voice
their opinion because of what they look
like
or who they are is important it's you
know
we have to keep talking about it because
nothing ever is destroyed
and one point that i was gonna ask is
whenever i bring up the subject of
venezuela people go oh but it wasn't
allowed to succeed
it was you know those catalyst pigs in
washington they were the one who brought
down the system there that they were the
ones who said oh you can't succeed
or implemented strategies so that the
economy failed
is this true i mean a lot of that i
think is just pure conspiracy theory
um if you want to criticize the us for
sanctions against certain countries fine
i think there's an argument to be made
that actually the best way
to help a country develop out
of socialist policy or help a developing
country just rise up in general is to
trade with it
you know trade is one of the best ways
that we can help liberalize countries
um but in the case of venezuela i mean
you are talking about a real dictator as
well
and i think u.s foreign policy remaining
extremely strong and against that is
vitally important this idea that the us
government made them
nationalize all their private companies
you know made them ration food made them
um turn into a socialist paradise is
absolutely ridiculous um and it's a
pretty weak cop-out i mean just say it's
just say it's bad just say it didn't
work just say that you
you can still hold very left-wing views
very progressive views
high tax high intervention views and
acknowledge
that venezuela north korea
mao's china the soviet union didn't work
because socialism and the extension of
it communism don't work
they're they they don't just not work
they kill hundreds
100 million people i think is the
current estimate around so
um let's just be honest about that get
that out of the way
and then we can have a legitimate policy
debate about tax rates isn't that the
fundamental issue with
socialist thinking is once you get to a
certain point and you want to
redistribute wealth
at that level you have to do it by force
because there comes a point where people
are like well i'm not giving away
90 of my wealth isn't that fundamentally
the flaw like as someone who comes from
russia the soviet union like it's basics
it's elementary to me
and to see in the west this rise of
socialism as this cool thing
it even baffles me it makes no sense to
me it makes no sense i mean
it's hard to imagine an id getting
behind an ideology that requires force
as you say there's no way for it to work
without that without that element of
of force and um that's really
it's it's very worrying that people
think that this is cool and trendy
um but i think that's because communism
seems to be
maybe the only ideology i can think of
right now anyway that gets away
with not having to deal with its real
world examples it gets a pass and i
don't really know why that is
um because you know you can criticize
capitalism all day long
no one gets upset when you criticize
capitalism and it's good that we do
right it's good that we critique it i
think it's
the best system we've come up with to
generate prosperity generate wealth lift
people up but it's not perfect
we'd be crazy to say that it's perfect
um
and you know we we're you can't
criticize communism because it's never
really been tried
and and that's dangerous because you
have to be able to
criticize something based on its real
world examples i think the issue there
is actually most people don't any have
any conception of
young people particularly they haven't
really studied history well enough
to and and i don't blame them like look
there's parts of the world that i don't
know anything about the reason i know
about socialism is that i experienced it
myself
right you probably don't go around
saying that something's really cool that
you know nothing about
yeah there was a horrific poll done in
the states
not too long ago where young where
people a range of people at different
age points
were asked um if more people died under
george w
bush or stalin and no millennials
it wasn't 50 but it was something like
30 percent of millennials
thought that more people had died under
george w bush
no than stalin no yes yes jesus [ __ ]
christ
yeah it's concerning right yeah so
that's i don't think george w bush is
that competent
was very good yeah yeah he was making he
was efficient yeah he was very very good
[Music]
do you think there is i mean the counter
argument to everything that we were
joking around about it but the counter
argument there would be
you know i put this to uh i guess a
couple of weeks ago
capitalism for young people their
experience of capitalism if you
entered the workforce after the
financial crisis
you're kind of going well i can't buy a
house i can't even buy a flat i probably
can't even buy a room in a flat at this
point right i'm really struggling
particularly someone like london
um my job prospects are uncertain the
economy
i don't know what's happening with it
i'm kind of like going well
you know i think the point that tom's
later from spike said to us it's
difficult to expect people
to be capitalist when they have no
capital right absolutely
it is and so isn't that the reason that
people are going well we need something
else they're not necessarily going
socialism is this great new thing
they're going well this thing didn't
work let's try something else and
socialism is they'll turn to yeah i
think there's a lot of truth to that
i don't think it totally justifies
turning to something that has been tried
and tested and failed
but there is a lot of merit in saying i
don't like what's happening this isn't
working
and i mean there are a lot of issues
that government needs to sort out that
we need to liberalize the planning
systems we can build more homes
you know the productivity puzzle hasn't
been solved
and there are a lot of reasons for young
people to feel like the deck stacked
against them
in many ways it is we have a huge issue
of intergenerational unfairness
and it's what we should be tackling
right now and continues to get ignored
um so i think those qualms are
completely legitimate and that's
it's good that we can criticize that and
then look to public policy to address
an array of issues that have to be
addressed so what would you suggest how
can we go about solving this mess is
there a certain certain things that we
could do
oh my gosh what a question no one ever
asks about what we can do do they
tell us about what's wrong yeah yeah um
well i i think for young people the
biggest question is housing yeah
without yeah and uh to me
it's it's not simply done but there is a
simple solution um you know the demands
honestly the way that the way that
people have been making those arguments
in the brexit debate
has so many flashbacks it is genuinely
disgusting
yeah it's horrible francis is a prime
example
um the biggest issue is that demand has
heavily outweighed supply and you know
we need to build more homes
and the adam smith institute did a
report a few years back when i was
working there
where they calculated that if you were
to liberalize
um 3.7 of london's greenbelt
all within 10 minute walking distance of
a train station you could build a
million homes
we will not solve the housing crisis
until those homes are built you can
tinker at the edges all you want but you
know the government's now questioning
their help to buy scheme
thinking they were helping young people
get on the housing ladder they actually
realize now it was pretty much economics
101 but they realize now
that that was further distorting the
housing market bringing in money when
there wasn't the supply to meet it
um you know it just causes house prices
to rise more every single time
they teach you that literally at a level
economics yeah
it's it's really i ca it's baffling
what the policies they bring in when
this is fundamental stuff
but i think i think whichever political
party is willing
to do this is willing to build more
homes and address the housing crisis in
a meaningful way
will win in a landslide it's just not
obvious who's going to do it and
obviously there are political
sensitivities in every party about why
you can't
but whoever can overcome that hurdle any
party i think would win in a landslide
but the conservatives can never do it
because if they say that they're going
to build on the green belt they will
alienate 80 of their core votes
um it would be it would be difficult to
do but i'm not convinced they could
never do it i think if you did it
and if you really targeted communities
and made those communities feel like
they had some control
over where the houses were being built
and what they looked like i think you
would actually potentially get more
popular support
okay so we have to let old people live
right yes we really do
you've made me forget the question
[Laughter]
geriatric genocide conversation that
won't make for a good clickbait
in support of old people living yes
yes cute last word there i was going to
ask you about austerity and cuts because
i think that's fundamentally an issue
where young people don't realize
that they're actually advocating against
something that's in their favor the
the the conversation about austerity
makes no sense because
the point of cuts and austerity even
though the cuts were actually very minor
in terms of the percentage of right and
this is something most people don't
realize i think like 50
of the budget was destroyed in this
progress
during the time of the coalition
government um between 2010 and 2015
on average spending was cut no 0.5 every
year
right that was it exactly 0.5
i'll tell you why i think young people
feel very strongly about this and
they've got
some legitimate grievances um the cuts
were disproportionate
uh okay to young people right so young
people as you say are trying to get into
the workforce after the financial crisis
that you know
everything's blown up where do we go
from now or where to go to now
and um all of a sudden you have
university tuition fees come in
um which is a policy i'm in favor of but
they came in very quickly with no time
to save
so you know people are dishing out for
that they're struggling to get on the
housing ladder struggling to get on the
jobs ladder
and meanwhile the benefits for older
people were completely protected the
triple lock on pensions winter fuel
allowance all of it's protected
and so while the cuts were quite minor
compared to what people actually think
they were they were disproportionate
and younger people would have felt them
more right and i think that again you
know just goes to this issue of
intergenerational unfairness
that was going to be my point which is
young people are going to be the ones
that are paying off this massive debt
they really are which is why you know i
don't think that we can be bribed with
10
000 pounds as the resolution foundation
wanted to hand out to all 25 year olds
and um ippr's recently put out a report
saying the same thing
we can't be bribed with a one-off ten
thousand pound payment to pay off
trillions and trillions of pounds down
the road that's
all going to be on us um and yeah i mean
austerity
is very much um something that young
people should
favor which is essentially just
responsible spending
um but because of that disproportionate
aspect
i think again understandably so you know
you're paying high tuition fees you're
in debt
you don't have a fantastic job or it's
not the job you wanted you can't get on
the housing ladder
you're working very hard and someone
comes along and says
i'll give you a house or i'll wipe your
debt i'll wipe your tuition fees i'll
help you up
and you go yes please yes please that
sounds great because nobody else is
helping
and the policies are not stacked in my
favor and they have a point
so do you think uh corbyn's gonna win
it'll
i don't make predictions after after the
past two years how can
anybody make a prediction yeah hey
everybody predicted trump would get
elected
just very few people predicted it before
the election year yeah that's very true
i put money on him to win did you yeah
i've never and but i didn't think he was
going to win
um i've never i had never bet anything
before this
um uh i'm not not a betting kind of gal
um i did not think he was going to win i
thought hillary clinton was going to win
but the odds were wrong and i was just
like this he's got a better chance than
what they're giving him
it's a good deal yeah exactly i was like
i don't think it's
i think he's i think this is wrong and
so i put a tenner on it
okay how much did you get i don't
remember it was like 40 quid or
something it was very exciting
yeah but i mean a lot of people around
me were not happy that night
i was like guys 40 quid and that didn't
seem to solve the problem
uh but yeah no i didn't think you could
see there's a solution bet on the guy
you don't like
yeah when he wins you're going to be
happy either way yeah
it's true silver lining yeah uh i don't
know i
i do think there's a chance that the
conservatives will end up handing
brexited britain over to the labour
party but
it's near impossible to say who the
leaders would be at that time what the
situation will be like how the public
feels about brexit
i mean i i am very happy to say i don't
know this is a show about experts and i
am not one
when it comes to is making random
predictions but i think that's part of
being an expert
i think more people need to say this is
what i know and this is what i don't
know i agree
and i think that has got to be a part of
our conversation everybody is always
trying to have an opinion
about stuff they don't understand and
it's really great that you would say
that
well i i think it's if you have a
philosophy you can kind of always
intuitively know how you're going to
feel about something
and it's great to express an opinion and
you know but
you have to you have to know the line
between opinion and fact
and you have to try to be you know we
all make mistakes and that's fine and
you can correct yourself
we should be nicer to people who do
correct themselves as well it shouldn't
you know be like
destroyed take down you should
thoughtful conversation unless it's owen
jones
oh i like owen jones why do you keep
destroying him
i think he punches back pretty well uh
he's he's very
he's very nice off camera um but i i you
know i think it's just important to
recognize what your opinion is and then
what an actual fact is sure
it's great to put forward your opinion
but don't confuse it with facts
yeah all right well listen we've done
feminism we've done uh
killing old people so that's not been
controversial let's talk
let's talk about the nhs and your views
on that because that's not that's
that's not going to trigger anyone in
this in this country is it uh
tell us your views i don't actually i'll
be honest with you i don't know a huge
amount about what you think about the
nhs
but a viewer and a friend of uh of ours
keeps messaging me when i said that you
were coming on he was like
you've got to ask her about the nhs did
he mention i don't like it
he did mention that you don't like it um
well
actually it's not it's actually not the
nhs that i don't like and
it's the attitude towards it so
the uk essentially created the principle
of universal access to healthcare back
in the 40s
and that's a very important principle
i'm from the states we don't have
universal access to healthcare i think
that's a bad thing
i do not advocate bringing the us system
anywhere else in the world
it's also extremely expensive and
unnecessarily so
the problem with the nhs is that since
its founding nobody's
been able to criticize it um it has
become
this god-like entity um people
write songs about it people do dances at
olympic ceremonies about it that was
weird in 2012 sitting in
the union bar watching like nurses do
flips
during the opening ceremony for the
olympics and the rest of the world was
looking at you guys being like
really the nhs is part of your opening
ceremony it was strange
people treat it like it cannot be
touched
and this is crazy it's a healthcare
service you know you have to be able to
speak about it honestly
because it it's only as good as the care
it delivers to its patients
and you know i don't think it's radical
to talk about what
germany is doing so what are the hard
truths about the nhs because look i'll
give you an example
uh two or three years ago i was playing
basketball i jumped up i miscalculated i
landed straight down on my arm i looked
down my arm was kind of zigzag shaped
like that so sorry
uh that's fine and you know look i'm
just
playing basketball like an idiot
suddenly three hours later but an
ambulance comes takes me to the hospital
about like 10 people are running around
straightening my arm giving me
ketamine or whatever it was knock me out
okay
that was fun yeah but but essentially i
get
all that treatment yeah here i am i'm an
idiot i broke my arm
i got this amazing treatment from
doctors who genuinely really care
you can tell that they're there because
they love doing what they do they love
taking care of people
what's wrong with that system why do you
wanna why do you want me to walk around
with a broken arm cake
i don't want you to walk around with a
broken arm um i i
i just recognize that every other
developed country in the world
apart from the us has developed a system
that would have done exactly the same
thing for you
except it would be better how well in
many situations it would be so one of
the areas where the nhs does best is
actually an emergency care
like if you break your arm they're very
good at picking you up and fixing it
um it does a lot worse when it comes to
longer-term illnesses
and quite serious illnesses like cancer
stroke survival rates things like that
um so on average uh the uk ranks in the
bottom
third of international health system
performance
it's on par with the czech republic in
slovenia
in terms of health care outcomes of
great countries
great countries but not what we would
think of as being you know world-class
when it comes to healthcare output
it could never be confused with belgium
or switzerland or france
um you know thousands more people die
when it comes to the five most common
types of cancer
in the uk than they would do on the
systems in switzerland or
germany and the problem is not the
universal access that's great
it's how the healthcare is actually
provided almost every other developed
country is recognized
that you need a combination of state
subsidy
to make sure everyone can pay for
healthcare have access to it
and then private provisions from the
private sector which are good at
efficiency
actually delivering the health care and
it looks nothing like america
uh you know it's a it's a very different
inclusive system
uh and here in the uk it's so
centralized
and it's so bureaucratic and it's so
deeply inefficient in the provisions of
healthcare
that people end up getting worse
treatment and you know i don't think
that the nhs is going to fundamentally
change tomorrow into some
mainland europe dream system uh you know
i but
it's crazy to me that we can't even talk
about those systems
um without people screaming that you
want the american system
and that we can't just be honest about
healthcare outcomes in the uk i mean
what is the point
if you're not getting really good
treatment uh and so it's the attitudes
that bother me not the nhs itself
so you've mentioned about switzerland
about germany
what are their systems because i've
always been a little bit in the dark
about them i don't fully understand them
how different how are they different to
the nhs for example
all the systems are different but if we
focus in on switzerland which would be
my preferred system for the uk and for
the u.s
it's basically universal insurance so
there are private providers of insurance
and private providers of health care
provisions
the state tops everyone up to make sure
that everyone has access to buy that
health insurance
it's compulsory and then you go out you
buy your health insurance and you have
significantly more patient choice and
control
over what kind of health care you're
getting access to
you get access to it faster you have
more choice there's a wider range of
provisions for you
it's a very nice combination of private
services and public services coming
together to deliver health care and how
much would that kind of insurance cost
so it ranges but there are serious
regulations on what you can charge
it's not a deregulated system by any
stretch of the imagination
and they spend slightly more on
healthcare they spend one to two
percentage of their gdp more
on healthcare which is why i've always
said i'm not fundamentally opposed to
the nhs having more money
but who's spending that money is the
money following the patient
or is the money following the
bureaucrats and if we were to
restructure so it followed the patient
it would probably be quite well spent
so um i'm not a radical on this one i
mean this is this is what i find funny
is that it's probably the topic that
is most dangerous to touch people get
most upset about and even more than
feminism
and the gender pay gap are likely to say
that you are
quite an extreme radical on but i just
don't think france is radical like i
don't think switzerland's radical i
don't think it's crazy to talk about
these things
um there are other health care systems
outside of the uk
and the attitude during the nhs is 70th
it was as if if you lived in these other
countries like babies weren't born
people didn't get access to treatments
like what do you think happens there
um australia is a really good example
you know similar population size
similar money going into their health
care system and they get better results
so let's try to learn a few things just
because we're leaving the eu doesn't
mean we don't have something to learn
from europe
and this would be a great area where we
could probably pick up a few tips
don't you think a lot of the celebration
the nhs
fundamentally comes from a distrust
towards a government
because i think the counter argument to
what you're saying is okay let's bring
in private practice
private companies and of course that's
fantastic but a lot of people go hang on
that is just a way for you to start
charging and once you start charging
then fees start going up and before you
know it we're in the american style
system
i mean take for example our universities
like when i went to university it was 1
000 pounds a year
now it's 9 000. well that's the fear
that's absolutely the fear and the
american system is very easy to point to
and that escalates the fear that people
have any concept
of of you paying for your health care
upsets people but what we have to
realize is that we are all paying for
health care
the nhs is not free the average family
and i think this is a conservative
estimate because it's from a few years
back
spends on average through their taxation
four thousand pounds
a year on health care on the nhs so it's
not free
the question you have to ask yourself
isn't is it free or am i paying
it's how far is that 4 000 pounds
getting me right now
and how far could it get me under a
different system and what would the
outcomes be like
and i think that's how you have to frame
it um and it's very disingenuous to say
that it's free here and that it's not
free in the states because that's just
that's not true money's coming from
somewhere um
but yeah i mean the states is just it's
it's a really easy way to dismiss
any argument around healthcare which is
um
unfortunate because nhs needs a bit of
help right now
yep and uh we need a little bit of help
because our time is almost up
so uh that that segway that made no
sense no i didn't
make no sense that was terrible i was
just trying to find a way to link what
you'd said to the fact that i was
getting worse as well
let's ask the final question it's
getting worse thanks for helping me out
man
i thought improv comedy was supposed to
be about yes and then you just you just
no it's
about destroying it's about the funniest
person winning
right how come i didn't win that one
then anyway um
a time's up so uh the last question that
we always ask is uh what is the one
thing that we're not talking about that
we should be talking about
i think the way in which
ideology is helping to realign politics
so by that i mean i don't think that the
definitions of left and right are very
helpful anymore
and i think that this is actually going
to translate to party politics
pretty soon i think the rise of trump
the rise of corbyn a lot of these
different
phenomenons are coming together and it
means that the way that we define
ourselves and our parties and our
politics is going to change and uh the
real
expert on this is dr steve davies at the
iaea
and he's got some fascinating theories
about the realignment and politics
and people should be listening to those
because i think it's going to happen
sooner than we think
and for a lot of people who are quite
tribal in their political beliefs
a lot's going to change throughout the
window fascinating we would love to get
them on the show then it sounds like
we will all right well uh thank you very
much for coming on
your twitter handle is uh at kate
a ndrs okay we'll put that in the bottom
of the video
follow kate kate andrews was taken was
it yeah
obviously i'm not over it
is there anything that you'd like to
promote have you got a book or anything
else that you would like
oh my gosh i don't have a book i don't
know if i have a book in me
that's yeah i'm always really in all of
people who write books
that's a that's great and what i'd flag
up the um ia podcast where ia
conversations on itunes
you can listen to steve davies and his
realignment theories and all other kinds
of things about how we're going to live
to 700 years old
perfect we'll put that in the video as
well that sounds good to me we're going
to live to 700 years old
and then francis is going to kill us all
yeah all of us
yeah and take all your houses and take
the houses that's how it works
uh if you enjoyed this week as always
follow us on
triggapod on twitter instagram we're on
facebook as well
subscribe to the youtube channel
obviously and if you're already
subscribed the most important thing
click that bell next to the subscribe
button so that you get notified
when we release a video yeah uh that was
it's been absolutely great thank you so
much for coming on having me this is so
much fun
and you need to up your game for next
week right i'll see you soon thanks bye